[Music]
back in the ussr russia's stalinesque
crackdown on journalism smacks of the
soviet era
life during wartime in exxon everything
is blocked everything is banned a
journalist flees russia and shares her
story and tick tock boom the ukrainian
influencer blowing up social media one
post at a time
hello i'm richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we don't cover
the news we cover the way the news is
covered
we begin with what remains of
independent journalism in vladimir
putin's russia where the mere mention of
the word war in relation to ukraine can
land you in prison for up to 15 years
where social media platforms have been
squeezed or completely blocked news
outlets have been shut down journalists
have fled the country and where citizens
seeking objective coverage of the
ukraine story have been left high and
dry as russia gets slapped with more
sanctions its reliance on western
technologies has been exposed its push
to replace them with tech developed at
home has been accelerated make no
mistake even before this invasion russia
was not an easy place to cover news for
some it was already a dangerous business
to be in but what has happened since the
invasion has been devastating for
journalism there our starting point this
week is lubianca square in moscow
[Music]
this is what an information war looks
like when it hits the streets
police in moscow's lubianca square
wrapped in body armor seizing the phones
of citizens
searching for evidence of resistance
tell-tale social media content about the
war in ukraine that can land people in
prison it's doom scrolling russian style
moscow is one of the most surveilled
cities in the world it has an incredible
system of facial recognition technology
and if you are to go out into the
streets when you know that you will be
punished for it
when it's your phone taken and
everything's including your contacts and
everything else yeah it's chilling
[Music]
all this is so
draconian
this approach is not sustainable long
term
and the more extreme measures
uh of policing and censorship the
government is using
the more we should recognize it
as a sign of weakness
as though there are two russia's old and
young online and offline
those who get their news from social
media which the authorities are now out
to control and the older generation that
relies on television channels and
talking heads that do the kremlin's
bidding
the messaging is holding out depending
on the social
demographic that it's aimed at so those
who are pensioners who rely on state tv
like first channel like racial
devastation
it's holding out for them so they don't
understand that this is an invasion of
the whole of ukraine
if we are talking about the russian
propagandists there is vladimir salabia
dimitri
margarita
olga scabieva and many many others
it is absolutely every presenter on
russian tv
people who for years have been nurtured
by russian power
they bribed actors they bribed comedians
they write bloggers
they did everything they could to create
an illusion of absolute support for the
military operation
just listen to the stories of
ukrainians who are calling their
relatives back um in russia trying from
their bomb shelters to tell them what's
going on and they're not buying their
stories because they believe what
they're seeing on russian tv
this did not happen overnight this is
the result of decades of just complete
brainwashing and bombardment of the most
um
spectacular unbelievable unhinged
propaganda
anyone calling the war in ukraine what
it is a war as opposed to the kremlin's
orwellian term a special military
operation is now at risk of 15 years
behind bars that new law applies to
foreign journalists as well and has
effectively paralyzed their outlets
operating in russia
normally
based in moscow but since the kremlin
shut down our bureau then revoked
accreditation
with television brought to heal long ago
the authorities used to tolerate a few
independent news outlets in print and
online that is no longer the case
dodged a news channel that lived on
youtube and the radio station ekamoskvy
are now out of business many of their
journalists have fled the country
independent media outlets in russia
brought an alternative point of view
they brought a little bit of a breathing
space
but now it's back to the ussr but back
to the kind of the stalinist era
it was incredible to see ejo mosquit one
of the most iconic radio independent
radio stations in russia shut down
so
yes that space has been squeezed to its
absolute limits
moving into that space are
kremlin-backed campaigns like the
emergence of the letter z
which is now used by russians to signal
their support for the invasion
the letter does not even exist in the
russian alphabet and it bears
uncomfortable similarities to the nazi
symbol
online the authorities have blocked
facebook partially jammed twitter and
intimidated tick-tock which no longer
allows russians to upload material
citizens can still use vpns to
circumvent the new measures
or messaging apps such as telegram to
get the word out for now but the
authorities are weaning russians off
their addiction to big tech platforms
born in silicon valley usa
and gradually a media space that looks
more like china's is taking
shape
in 2018
the russian media regulator
uh tried to ban
uh the telegram
but they had to lift the ban because it
was really hurting russian businesses
and there are numerous businesses in
russia created around
monetization of youtube and instagram
technologically russia is absolutely not
prepared for any
kind of sovereign internet i think
it would be
[Music]
doable to decouple from western
technology platforms the best developers
and the best coders in the world tend to
come from russian universities and
they've been developing their own
platforms and their own clones they rip
off western products and in some cases
they make them better so they have the
know-how certainly in technology
but what is even more scary is that
russia can turn off the internet
it is quite a realistic scenario
the authorities can make an intranet a
trimmed internet in which all
information is filtered
and then no vpn can help you nothing
will help you
however to take these steps right now is
quite difficult and it depends how far
the government is prepared to go in
order to continue covering up the truth
michael nachi is one of the journalists
who has fled russia he has a show on
youtube with more than four hundred
thousand subscribers
did not wait for the invasion to leave
moscow he saw what was coming he has set
up shop in tbilisi georgia which means
naki can still cover the story speak his
mind
those journalists who have fled abroad
they lose everything they lose their
house their family the opportunity to
make a living
but they continue to try to tell the
citizens of russia what is happening
because now the whole world is watching
the reaction of russian citizens
as long as it is possible to speak
we will try to speak
and when things become more difficult we
will use typewriters
we will print our information and send
it out
the printed word is no match for news
channels that reach millions of russians
at the flip of a switch a click on a
keyboard
they are the dominant domestic weapons
vladimir putin has in this information
war the ukrainian president knows that
and on thursday vladimir zelanski warned
the pseudo-journalists who populate
those studios in moscow that one day
somebody will come for them
a message for the kremlin's messengers
another one that will fail to reach the
audience it's really intended for
the russian people
while many countries have spoken out
against the invasion of ukraine one of
russia's major trading partners china
has remained officially neutral but the
media output from there tells a
different story flo phillips is here
with more richard the chinese
administration is at least publicly
staying impartial promoting peace talks
abstaining from the un vote and putting
out statements like this from its
foreign ministry all about respecting
and safeguarding the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of all countries
but that's not what we're seeing on
chinese media cctv the state-owned
broadcaster accessible to more than one
billion viewers referred to the russian
invasion not as a war but as a special
military operation sound familiar
that's terminology made in the kremlin
now coming out of beijing then there are
the repeated false claims that president
zelensky had fled the ukrainian capital
or this past monday that washington had
funded the development of biological
weapons in ukrainian labs
all that gets posted and reposted in
china's enclosed social media ecosystem
where according to a leaked directive
media outlets were told to avoid posting
quote anything unfavorable to russia or
pro-western
that plays out in content like this a
video of russian soldiers sharing food
with ukrainian children or this image
during the rounds comparing the
devastation of u.s bombing in syria with
a seemingly serene and peaceful scene in
kiev
others are more obviously anti-western
like this cartoon published by the
global times a daily tabloid under
chinese communist party control titled
the true firestarter
the country's highly censored media
space means that opposing viewpoints are
muted and it leaves chinese citizens
with a selective airbrushed version of
the ukraine story not that far off the
state-controlled story the official one
in vladimir putin's russia
thanks flo
back to russia now in what looks like
the closing chapter in the story of the
country's sole remaining independent
television channel
dodged known in english as tv rain was
taken off the airwaves back in 2014
and moved its journalism to youtube
in 2020 and 2021 when opposition leader
alexei navalny was poisoned then
arrested and russians were taken to the
streets
dodged totaled 1.1 billion views
streamed online about a month ago we
interviewed one of the channel's hosts
ekaterina katrikaze at the time she was
in moscow ten days later russia invaded
ukraine since then dodged has been
banned most of its leadership team has
fled russia leaving a black hole of
information behind
what follows are two interviews with the
katarina katrikadzi the one before the
invasion and one thereafter
[Music]
some kind of
censorship some kind of steps by the
government
we could not imagine that it would
happen so fast that they would just ruin
everything
in a couple of days that they would just
shut down
[Music]
the war with seve tiberine with dorst
started in 2014
when
the popularity of our channel was so
high that the government of russia
understood that something should be done
we have millions of viewers and the
journalists and anchors of tiberian were
the most famous people in russia
dorst was
the only liberal
alive tv channel discussing things that
were banned on other tv stations we had
the whole specter of views and opinions
the representatives of government were
here discussing and sometimes arguing
with
representatives of opposition of liberal
views so after the revolution and then
crimea annexation and then warren
donbass
doors became a problem for the
government
[Music]
youtube
it really has changed everything in our
lives in russia everything was banned
it's a total censorship here in this
country
and at some stage people discovered that
youtube may be used for the political
journalism the issue with youtube is
that
the rules of the game are different
there
there are not
you know people who can
ban something
who can write down banned bad figures
that you should not cover should not
interview or something like that
this is the territory of freedom
and people if they see that you know
there is something wrong with you that
there is falsehood
there are lies on air they just don't
watch you this is what happens on
youtube and this is
totally different from anything you can
see on
on the traditional classic
tv channels in russia
[Music]
i don't think that they will shut down
the youtube this is kind of
unbelievable situation i'm not sure that
they can do it and not because they are
afraid of shutting down tv raid on
youtube or other independent journalists
it's not about that it's because youtube
is not a platform for us only right this
is a platform for
mothers with kids who watch
masha and the bear or whatever you like
but they have billions of views this is
different this is a huge army of people
who need youtube they cannot just switch
it off
foreign
here
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
obviously i'm out of country
we were obliged to leave russia because
of the situation
which was devastating we have faced
military censorship we have faced
serious signals from different people
different sources that
we were not safe in russia anymore and
also me personally and a couple of my
colleagues were getting
threats from different people
calls messages terrible things the
website of tv raid was blocked and to me
this was the final signal final call i
was absolutely sure
no chance that we would survive in this
country so that's why we have left
[Music]
there was no person in russia except
vladimir putin who could
who could see this was coming so fast we
were expecting
some kind of problems with youtube
some kind of problems with social media
because we
we could see the obvious reality that
you know the state media was bombing
people
with the propaganda 24 7. and we were
free people working working on youtube
saying the truth you know during this
spirit of war
we've had 25 million views daily there's
so many people millions of people who
understand that they need to to see the
reality that they need to see
alternative information to understand
what's going on
there is no truth in russia right now
everything is blocked everything is
banned everything is destroyed almost
everyone tries to run away
almost everyone is trying now to find
the tickets and you can see that there
there is a problem of getting out of the
country right now which makes me
absolutely crazy because there are some
people who i really care about and they
cannot leave
this country we will try our best to
work
outside of the country
there will be some people inside of it
of course there are always brave people
who stay there and um yeah
i'm hoping for the best in spite of the
fact that this situation
is unprecedented
russia has never faced anything like
that
youtube is really very important for us
but
we lived without it
you know there was a life without
youtube it will be a life without
youtube
and you know another thing is that
there is always a way
to fight
this new bands and blocks
in internet we are stronger
on internet than the russian government
this old
soviet style man who don't even get how
it works you know so yeah i think we are
more talented and we're more strong that
uh these people so we we're gonna be
okay
[Music]
we don't want to see it as an end we
want to see it as a
temporary slowdown as a temporary pause
because
i'm sitting right now in the hall of the
hotel
um
and uh all of my friends and colleagues
are sitting in the room chatting and
trying to plan what to do what's going
to be next up how to how to leave
after this catastrophe
and i can see the faces of these people
um i can see that they're all big
fighters and they're not gonna give up i
mean it's impossible to to stop these
people they're too brave they're too
smart these are the people who will make
russia a free and prosperous country
again so i'm sure that something will be
done i'm sure that tv reign will be back
in some kind of form and i'm sure that
it's not the end
and finally ukrainians can still get
access to sites like facebook twitter
and tick talk that have been blocked or
crippled in russia by the kremlin and
president zielinski is not the only one
making the most of that valeria
shachennock is a tick-tocker based in
the ukrainian city of cherniev she's a
young photographer who is using that
platform and a knack for dark humor to
show what life is like living in a
bunker millions of views and a couple of
interviews with the bbc and cnn later
she has made a name for herself by
telling an important story in the
simplest of ways we'll leave you now
with some of her videos and we'll see
you next time here at the listening post
[Music]
uh-huh
[Music]
[Music]
she let me squeeze
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
my mission to show the whole world that
it's happened now in real life and you
can see now war in tik tok